you would think when it comes to Man vs
nature the hardest thing you'd have to
deal with is the weather but in folklore
it's just as likely that the plants will
kill you faster than the weather ever
could and how they do so can be very
disturbing book science fiction media
and even musicals have expanded on the
Trope of the killer plan ranging from
Flora that exudes toxic fumes to ones
that invasively domesticate whole
planets for food and the mutated ones
that make human clones under the control
of the Great Potato but not all of it is
fiction many killer plants are actually
based off of real species like the Venus
flytrap or the upas tree so make sure to
water your plants at home unless they
acquire murderous intent